j'ai barcelone dans les poumons et co je
peux dire de ma prison
et tout ce qu'elle a à l'abandon c'est
vrai
chez par stallone dans le poumon
viva hasta luego pas sale gosse je veux
dire quand on fait la publicité pour le
gars mais quand on fait trop de gardes
vient tellement beau qu'on est bon pour
l'insecte
bonjour daniel g philipe
oui j'ai beaucoup aimé ton émission sur
le sur les boîtes échangistes et puis
aussi une sur le tableau de naissance du
monde à propos de la naissance du monde
ce que tu sais pourquoi ils viennent
souvent une glace sur ce tableau est
bien fait pour éviter les coups de
langue
bonne soirée
salut c'est génial merde là bas si j'y
suis avec les répondeurs du galon gluck
est revenue enfin bon j'ai toujours été
un peu versé dans ça que j'ai pas du
tout aimé par tous et votre amalgame
avec la bosnie ça n'a rien à voir
je pense que personne aucun bris god is
known as aimé ça ainsi vous confondez
peut-être une triste farce médiatique
ça c'est votre problème sais pas
peut-être que vous êtes obligés de le
faire mais moi aussi je crois pas à une
guerre d'espagne surtout pas à soutenir
un intégrisme musulman et encore moins
les intérêts des états unis que je doute
que je transporte un impôt si convaincu
ne sont pas l'intérêt des français alors
évitez nous parler des victimes des
idéologies à la mode parce que ça c'est
vraiment très dur et n'oubliez pas que
comme bonne émission que vous avez fait
aussi sur un an aussi sur les pauvres
n'a pas n'oubliez pas que ces gens-là
sont payés par des agents américains
pour recevoir oui bonjour je m'appelle
recherche habite ma vie la vie dans 95
vieux je viens d'être émue mme alors aux
larmes par la série sur sur la guerre
d'espagne
je veux dire sur sur ces brigades
internationales mon frère y est tu étais
moi j'ai 64 ans j'ai toujours suivi
pièce toute cette histoire enfin tous de
cette lutte anti fasciste j'ai perdu mes
parents qui ont été massacrés ou suite
j'ai ainsi juive
je suis communiste de coeur je ne milite
pas je ne milite plus pour vos un moment
donné j'étais tellement monsieur daniel
mrb vous en faites trop
à force de dénigrer toutes les idées
politiquement incorrect vous aurez
laissé contraire avec votre auditoire
album vous êtes la caricature de l'idiot
utile de fascisme est mort et enterré
depuis deux générations en est que le
communisme existe toujours dans le monde
et surtout chez nous avec nos folies
dans intellectuelle médias et les
politiques bravo de faire l'apologie
d'un régime qui a fait 60 millions de
victimes
un jour vous aurez à répondre de votre
haine merci à l'ours n'est pas pour
parler de moi mais moins voilà je
voudrais faire il faut réagir il faut ce
qu'il faut c'est avoir une nouvelle
conscience politique ou d'un très bon
goût